hey there guys so there's a small change
of plans originally this was going to be
a four part series and part four was
gonna be focused on mobility I was gonna
end my performance and flips myself to
see how much the training had benefited
me that's still on the way but it turns
out that grant is crazy good at martial
arts tricking which is essentially
weaponized acrobatics these are the
kinds of kicks that Nightwing might
actually use and they showcase the kind
of power and body awareness you'd need
to move like him in this video grants
going to demonstrate some basic moves
and provide an overview of the subject
there's also some training advice
including another core workout that he
uses that I think is insanely good and
hits all the major muscles of the core
described in the last video but in a
faster and more explosive manner so
enjoy and who knows what will happen in
part 5
[Music]
in this video we're going to be looking
at some of the acrobatic martial arts or
tricking techniques that Nightwing may
possibly use in his arsenal these moves
came from many different disciplines
including traditional martial art styles
gymnastics wushu capoeira and breakdance
to name but a few and since the late 90s
have been grown into a much broader
discipline known as tricking martial
arts tricking or sometimes extreme
martial arts now this is a little
disclaimer these techniques are clearly
not supposed to be practical it's kind
of funny I have to mention that
obviously Nightwing's a fictional
character and this video is just
intended to look at some of the tricky
moves and real training methods that he
might use what he too really exists so
what this video is gonna be focusing on
primarily is the actual techniques
themselves with a little gymnastic core
conditioning thrown in as well at the
end and as we have limited time this is
just gonna be a general overview of a
few of the moves rather than a full-on
tutorial for each but we may be able to
go into more detail on that sort of
thing in future videos in my experience
the way to train the body most
effectively to do something that
requires a high level of body control
and coordination is overwhelmingly just
by doing the activity over and over
again and that should take up around 80
to 90% of your actual work on these
skills one of my favorite people to
listen to and learn from is Feroz Sahabi
he was an amazingly knowledgeable MMA
trainer most famous for working with
George st. Pierre and somebody who's far
ahead of his time in my opinion for as
doesn't believe in giving up any days of
actual practice upon your skills in
favor of strength and conditioning work
rather that stuff should be done after
the actual skill practice not as a
priority not to a level where your body
becomes too fatigued to train the next
day and training like this is gonna
engage the said principle which stands
for specific adaptation to impose
demands which is pretty self-explanatory
and why there isn't really one type of
fitness or strength for example if you
take a high level boxer and a high level
wrestler both extremely fit and adapted
to their disciplines but now you take
the wrestler and have them do a few
boxing rounds not only is he going to
look super clunky but is gonna be
exhausted in no time because he's not
used to that skill and the same is true
in vice-versa a big part of what helps
this is also have an incredibly
economical technique the skill that
you're
simp which also goes a long way towards
being faster overall now there's many
different styles of tricky moves and
we're gonna be focusing on primarily
techniques that night we may potentially
use as an attack or an evasion with that
in mind the first thing you really want
to develop is your basic kicking
techniques if your basic kicks are
sloppy and on economical when you start
adding spins and jumps to them you're
already gonna be starting at a weak
foundation and there won't be very fast
and effective i'd recommend practicing
these in both a traditional line kick in
style that you see in Taekwondo classes
as well as doing some slow kicking
drills holding on to something for
balance
now the first move we're going to be
looking at is a jump 360 Crescent kick
which is quite self-explanatory you jump
spin round and kick with the outside of
your foot in a Crescent kick in manner
the only prerequisite to this is rarely
a crescent kick and you can use this
move to begin combinations of others as
well flash kick which is basically just
a lay out backflip with a kick in there
made famous by Kyle from Street Fighter
be comfortable with back tuck and it can
also help to be good at a layup back if
you want that nice arched flash kick as
well also be sure not to get too late in
the move to make sure you can see the
kick clearly aerial is basically a no
handed cartwheel and the obvious
prerequisite to this is a fast and
powerful cartwheel or 100 cartwheel it
can be added to with a kick at the end
with the trailing leg and you can also
make it more powerful by using a spin
hook kick beforehand tornado is one of
the foundational kicks to many other
jumps spinning kicks and it's really
important to have it down solidly to
more easily progress to high level moves
now the tornado progresses nicely to a
540 kick which is like a tornado kick
where you land on the kicking leg hence
the need for a high and powerful tornado
kick with the chest held high to gain
air time
[Applause]
[Music]
Chii 900 is the same takeoff position as
a tornado kick and 540 but there's an
extra spin before the kit comes out and
in this one you just kick in like a
tornado kick as well
[Music]
a side swipe is very much like a fight
for ticket where we take off kick then
land on the same leg however it's done
at an inverted angle meaning the hips
are higher than the head whereas the 540
is doing more upright like a tornado
kick
[Music]
the touchdown raise or rise has the same
take off as a sideswipe and is mainly
used as a transition to other moves the
difference is you put your hand down
when inverted to take some of your body
weight and create a powerful set up for
swing through moves like a gainer or
corkscrew in this clip you can see me
using the TD raise as a follow-up to a
sideswipe
[Music]
this is the butterfly twist which is the
follow-on from the butterfly kick and
this is a really nice-looking move that
I originally saw in wushu in these clips
I'm doing an advanced version called a
hyper hook where you land on the
opposite leg and throw out a hot kick at
the end finally we're looking at
cartwheel setup techniques it's like a
roundoff in gymnastics but is able to be
combined with tricking kicks better when
done side to side as a cartwheel here
I'm doing car Arabian which is a basic
one and then a twisting variation
afterwards
now on to the gymnastic core
conditioning exercises these are to be
done with no rest in between and they're
quite difficult so if you starting out
I'd recommend three to five sets of
three to five reps three times per week
and build from there okay so the first
one is the vo try to fold your torso
against your legs as closely as you can
with your arms going past your legs on
each repetition the alternate veal
touching one hand to the opposite leg
simultaneously keeping your legs and
arms as straight as possible and then
return into the hollow position before
repeating the took up try to get your
knees as close to your chest as you can
and then push them back out I like to do
these quite fast and explosively hollow
or dish rocks I'm rocking my weight back
and forward using my legs and arms to
counterbalance myself each time putting
strain on the core to remain steady
place the lead elbow on the floor and
hand on the head and the other hand flat
on the ground to push ahead and arm off
the floor as you lift your legs straight
into the air at the same time be sure
not to fold forward at the waist on
these and keeping a nice straight line
our chops these are kind of like reverse
Fiats but obviously with not as much
movement pretty easy to see what's going
on in this clip and lastly this the
hollow or dish hold the only part of
your body that should really touch the
floor are you bought on your lower back
hold this for fifteen to thirty seconds
okay so I've got all the exercises
listed here V ups alternate V ups took
ups hollow rocks oblique side bends our
chops and Hollow hold remember to start
with three to five sets of three to five
reps three times per week and then build
from there it's better to remain
consistent and use the principle of
compounding rather than to burn yourself
out and not be able to train for a few
days after or whatever I hope you
enjoyed this video as always please
follow me on my Instagram which is where
I tend to upload most of my training
clips and things like that and feel free
to send me a message with any questions